[موسيقى]
كده الحزب الشيوعي الصيني ضروره القمعي
عمليه التسلل والتخريب من قبل القوى
المعاديه وفقا للقانون وشدد بيان للحزب
عقب اجتماع اللجنه السياسيه والقانونيه
المركزيه له على ضروره قمع الاعمال غير
القانونيه والاجراميه التي تخل بالنظام
الاجتماعيه مع المحافظه بجديه على
الاستقرار الاجتماعيه الشامل اكد الاجتماع
على ضروره حل النزاعات في الوقت المناسب
والمساعده في حل الصعوبات العمليه للشعب
وكانت مراسله الجزيره قد افادت بان
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه المطالبه برفع
الاغلاقات في مختلف المدن الصينيه توقفت
عزيزه الامنيه مشدده في العاصمه بجين وفي
شنغهايه اظهرت صور انتشارا مكثفا لقوه
الشرطه في شنغهايه حاله دون خروج احتجاجات
مناهضه لقيود كورونا افادت وكاله رويترز
نقل عن مصادر من المشاركين في احتجاجات
بان السلطات الصينيه حققت مع بعض
المحتاجين واستد عطل المشاركين في
المظاهرات الى مراكز الشرطه
وفي منطقه
العاصمه الصينيه اعلنت السلطات اعفاء كبار
السن والاطفال والطلبه الذين يدرسون عبر
الانترنت من اجراء اختبارات كورونا بشكل
يوميا اوضحت السلطات الصينيه لتخفيف
اجراءات الفحص اليومي للفيروس تشمل عده
مدن ومناطق اخرى في البلاد منها مقاطعه
شونج تشينغ وواندونج الجنوبيه وقالت انه
سيتم اعفاء سكان الاحياء التي لم تسجل
حالات اصابه من اجراء الفحص لمده خمسه
ايام تاتي هذه الخطوه بعد احتجاجات شعبيه
التي تنفذها الحكومه منذ ظهور الفيروس قبل
نحو ثلاث سنوات
معنا الان من بيجين مراسله شيماء اهلا بك
هل يمكن القول بان كل هذه الاحتجاجات قد
انتهت بشكل نهائي
الاحتجاجات التي استمر على مدى الايام 3
الماضيه وذلك من خلال الاستجابه السريعه
بتخفيف بعض الاجراءات في المناطق التي
شهدت الاحتجاجات مثل العاصمه الصينيه
بيجين مدينه شنغهاي همم مدينه اوروموش
حاضره مقاطعه الغربيه الصين وايضا همم
المقاطعات الجنوبيه مثل وايضا همم مقاطعه
كوانتو تحديدا مدينه لكن هنالك مقاطع
فيديو همم على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الصينيه قبل حضرها اظهرت بان ليله الامس
كان هناك بعض الصدامات على نطاق ضيق جدا
بين بعض
المتساكنين في مجمع سكنيين ما زال يخضع لي
الاغلاق حاول همم السكان ازاله الحواجز
القصديريه التي تمنعهم من الخروج وذلك
خلال اصطدام اللي مع قوات الامن التي
حاولت منعه من ازاله هذه كويس السلطات في
المدينه اكدت بانها سوف تزيلها خلال
الساعات المقبله وذلك استجابه لطلب
المواطنين في تلك المجمعات السكنيه خاصه
وان الصين الان دخلت في مرحله تطبيق
الاصدار الاخير من ال- اا من الاجراءات
الاحترازيه لفايروسكوب 19 والتي تلغي
تماما الاغلاق الكامل للمجمعات السكنيه
باكملها اولمود باكملها او حتى لبنيه
باكملها عند اكتشاف حاله اصابه فيها سيتم
فقط اغلاق السكنيه او همم المنزل الذي
يقتله الشخص الذي تتاكد اصابته 19 بكري
هذا الاغلاق سيخفف كثيرا من الاعباء
الاقتصاديه وحتى همم الاجتماعيه بالنسبه
للسكان الذين يتواجدنا في المناطق التي
تصنف على انها متوسطه وعاليه الخطوره هنا
نتحدث ايضا عن العاصمه الصينيه بيجين التي
تصنف فيها منطقه على انها
الخطوره يهمنا لك ايضا تخفيفات فيها من
حيث عدم همم اجباريه القيام بفحص كوبس 19
بشكل يومي سواء لكبار السن او الاطفال او
حتى
الطلبه والتلاميذ الذين يدرسون عن بعض من
منازلهم وذلك بعد التعليق الدراسه في
المدارس منذ اسابيع في منطقه العاصمه
الصينيه